salut à tous bienvenue à bruxelles une
fois de plus nous sommes ici cette
semaine pour commenter une très riche
actualité européenne
cette semaine direction kiev en ukraine
un an après la révolution nous sommes
retournés à maidan dans la capitale
d'une ukraine désormais divisé les défis
sont nombreux pour le nouveau parlement
en place et les attentes de la
population énorme mais d'abord
l'actualité réforme insuffisante c'est
un tacle cinglant kangala merkel a
envoyée à la france qui a jusqu'au mois
de mars pour revoir sa copie avant
d'être sanctionné par bruxelles alors la
france vilain petit canard de l'union
c'est la question de la semaine et elle
est posée par simon barbarie
et un petit coup de griffe pour la
france de la part d'angela merkel au
sommet de sa popularité outre 20 et
juste avant son plébiscite à la tête du
parti chrétien démocrate allemand la tse
d où la chancelière exprime le fond de
sa pensée
les déficits publics français sont trop
élevés et les réformes insuffisantes
la france mettrait en danger les
équilibres économiques de l'europe et la
crédibilité des règles communes voilà de
quoi doucher l'optimisme français autour
de la loi macro intitulé croissance et
activités et présenté cette semaine en
conseil des ministres le gouvernement on
reste zen et ça m'agace pas du tout moi
aussi ma fille marie de dire des choses
sur l'allemagne
jeudi par exemple quand l'allemagne
j'aimerais bien qu'ils investissent plus
s'il ya quelques sa glace c'est bien
jean luc mélenchon le député européen du
parti de gauche s'est fendu sur twitter
d'un ferme hélas en allemand dans le
texte j'ai décidément cette semaine il
n'y a pas que de l'autre côté du rhin
qu'on enjoint la france à accélérer ses
réformes
jean tirole prix nobel d'économie
français invite lieu aussi son pays à
suivre l'exemple de l'allemagne
l'urgence réformer l'état et le marché
de l'emploi
de son côté la commission européenne
attend des mesures supplémentaires avant
de rendre son avis sur la conformité du
budget français en mars prochain
alors la france mauvaise élève de
l'europe
la france mauvais élèves de l'europe
c'est la question posée cette semaine
par simon barbarie et pour y répondre
c'est michèle alliot marie que je reçois
bonjour bonjour merci d'être avec nous
michel allez marion ne vous présente
plus tout du moins aux téléspectateurs
français ancien is de la justice de la
défense de l'intérieur des affaires
étrangères vous êtes donc ici au titre
de députée européenne membre du coup
parti populaire européen
est ce que la france selon vous est le
vilain petit canard de l'union
certainement pas le vilain petit canard
et est d'abord je ne voudrais pas qu'on
parle de la france que l'on parle du
gouvernement français qui ne tient pas
ses engagements et qui ne mène pas la
politique qui serait cohérente avec les
exigences européennes c'est une chose la
france c'est autre chose
vous savez l'attachement que j'ai à mon
pays et je ne supporte pas qu'on
critique mon pays surtout quand c'est
pas de l'action d'un gouvernement alors
je vais vous ramener un petit peu en
arrière vous étiez vous-même aux
affaires sous le gouvernement de
françois fillon et la présidence de
nicolas sarkozy
déjà à l'époque vous ne teniez pas les
objectifs de convergence dans les
critères de convergence de maastricht et
les objectifs de déficit et de dette
publics donc finalement est ce qu'on
n'est pas dans une posture à dire le
gouvernement de françois hollande et de
manuel valls et auparavant jean marc
ayrault
non pour une raison très simple c'est
que il y avait des efforts et de rézé
fort de réformes profondes qui ont été
faits souvenez vous les critiques et
qu'a eue le gouvernement de françois
fillon et de nicolas sarkozy lorsque
l'on à diminuer le nombre des
fonctionnaires puisqu'en france nous
avons le plus grand nombre de
fonctionnaires de de toute l'europe
d'autre part en ce qui concerne les
déficits n'oubliez pas non plus la crise
de 2008 où tous les pays européens
à ce moment là ont accru leurs déficits
pour faire face à cette crise de alors
là on voit que ces mêmes merkel quand
même qui tient le leadership en europe
est ce que on ne va pas trop loin dans
cette forme d'allégeance à berlin je ne
pense pas qu'il y ait une forme
d'allégeance à berlin je crois qu angela
merkel d'ailleurs elle-même déplore
d'être un peu seul la même est de
l'europe
et elle rappelle que effectivement que
ce soit avec jacques chirac
où que ce soit avec nicolas sarkozy dans
la grande tradition franco allemande
l'europe avait une direction
on l'europe avaient un poids lorsqu'il y
avait l'entente franco-allemande ça fait
des décennies que l'on dit effectivement
que quand le couple franco-allemand
marche bien l'europe marche bien or dans
le monde actuel nous avons besoin d'une
europe qui marche à la fois parce qu'il
ya une concurrence avec des grands
ensembles d'un milliard d'habitants et
je les vois que la chine va pas c'est
donc la première puissance économie est
dans l'air en n'est pas très loin
derrière et quand nous voyons le
développement technologique de l'âne
c'est la même chose
l'amérique latine malgré les problèmes
qu'il ya aujourd'hui un peu lié à la
crise et quand même un continent qui
avance considérablement il est évident
que nous avons besoin de l'europe c'est
ce que j'essaie de l'europe est à la
traîne
oui et puis surtout il faut qu'on y
verrait des mois si vous voulez j'ai été
promis que je retournerai dans les 18
départements de l'euro circonscription
depuis que j'ai été élu je suis retourné
dans chacun parce que je pense que cette
politique de proximité est indispensable
pour se faire comprendre aux gens que
leur effet d'alléger les contraintes
mais que l'europe c'est une nécessité
une nécessité économique si nous voulons
garder notre niveau
un pays de 65 millions d'habitants comme
la france même avec tous ces atouts ne
comptent pas par rapport à la chine d'un
milliard d'aviation à l'aide d'un
milliard d'habitants
nous avons besoin de nous adosser à un
ensemble comme l'europe qui fait 500
millions d'habitants et qui nous permet
d'avoir notamment les moyens de financer
une recherche qui nous permette d'avoir
la marche technologique d'avant ce qui
va nous permettre effectivement d'être
deux des concurrents sérieux solide de
nous défendre a en quelque sorte face à
la chine à l'inde ou à l'amérique latine
alors allez tout à l'heure l'union
européenne a aussi un poids politique et
la semaine prochaine donc une résolution
sur la reconnaissance de la palestine
devrait ou non être votée ici au
parlement européen
il s'est à peu près pas c'est la même
chose la semaine dernière à l'assemblée
nationale
je voudrais qu'on regarde ces images de
claude bartolone
voici le résultat du scrutin pour 339
contre 151
l'assemblée nationale a adopté
michèle alliot marie on le voit en
france c'est un vote symbolique mais
après la suède après l'espagne la
semaine prochaine le parlement européen
est ce que vous vous voterez cette
résolution de reconnaissance de la
palestine
il va d'abord falloir savoir quelle
résolution sera soumise au vote car
aujourd'hui vous avez une résolution qui
vient de la gauche et du parti
socialiste en fait dénuée socialistes
européens ceux-ci sont extrêmement
divisé la suède qui avait pris cette
initiative a vu son gouvernement
être obligé de partir d'aujourd'hui il
ya de budget oui d'accord mais c'était
lié à la reconnaissance de
l'investissement non mais je dis que
ceux qui ont pris des initiatives
effectivement ne sont plus là il ya
énormément de division au sein des
socialistes sur la résolution qui a été
soumise et une autre résolution qui est
celle du ppe qui éventuellement peut
venir donc je vais attendre de voir
quelle sera la résolution qui sera
soumise c'est la révolution socialiste
je ne voterai pas et systèmes de jeu et
e6 et le ppe c'est une résolution qui
est beaucoup plus je dirais je vais pas
dire modéré je dirais beaucoup plus
constructive s'ils voulaient c'est un
problème que je connais bien j'ai eu à
le traiter comme ministre des affaires
étrangères il faut trouver une solution
les fondamentaux de cette solution nous
les avons depuis longtemps
et d'ailleurs ce que j'ai constaté c'est
que finalement il y a une très grande
proximité il ya un quasi accord sur les
ses fondamentaux
les deux sénateurs de 61,2 et a gagné
madame alliot marie et écouter ont
encore une fois je crois que quand on
discute avec les gens et je les ai tous
vus en dehors du hamas mais je les ai
tous vus je crois qu'on est beaucoup
plus proche et qu'il y a effectivement
des solutions et y compris probablement
le point le plus grave ayant me paraît
plutôt être jérusalem comme capitale des
deux états contre jose est le véritable
langue la nation et qui est lié aux
frontières dont nous parlions tout à
l'heure mais le véritable problème c'est
un conte problème de confiance c'est à
dire que chacun dit s'il doit y avoir un
d'accord finalement l'autre ne le
respectera pas donc ce sur quoi il faut
travailler c'est beaucoup plus la
garantie qu'il y a
cette confiance il est évident que si
nous voulons réussir cela il faut que la
reconnaissance de l'état palestinien
wass partie de ce tout ça toujours été
si vous voulez un élément essentiel
reconnaissance éventuelle une
reconnaissance mutuelle la
reconnaissance du droit d'israël à vivre
tranquillement dans ses frontières c'est
ça qu'il faut obtenir et c'est pas par
des déclarations à l'emporte-pièce qui
surtout en ce qui concerne le parlement
européen qu'il n'a aucune compétence
on hamm est rien venir pas grand chose
ça ça risque plutôt de crisper une
situation plutôt que d'apporter une
situation dernière question michèle
alliot marie
on voit la situation en ukraine qui
seraient potentiellement vers une
désescalade ce que vous y croyez ce
qu'il faut continuer de parler à
vladimir poutine ou est-ce qu'il faut
pas été occultée moi je pense que la
première chose j'ai eu l'occasion dans
mes fonctions de rencontrer à plusieurs
reprises détenir poutine
ce n'est pas en l'ostracisme en ne lui
parlant pas en faisant des annonces en
dehors sans lui avoir dit en direct ce
que l'on pense qu'on fait avancer les
choses
et deuxièmement ce que je dis aussi
c'est que moi je suis très inquiète de
l'escaladé verbale en plus sans contact
à laquelle nous assistons depuis des
mois il est temps d'aller vers la
désescalade
avec toutes les garanties que l'on peut
prendre mais ça c'est aussi à nous le
dire et l'europe a un rôle essentiel à
jouer
il est temps que l'on entende l'europe
sur le plan international et ça c'est
super j'ai dit aussi à madame
nogueirinha effectivement il est
nécessaire aujourd'hui que l'europe
prenne conscience qu'elle est une
puissance politique autant qu'elle est
une puissance économique et qu'elle se
comporte comme tel
donc le message est passé j'imagine à
malabo guérini donc la toute nouvelle
haute représentante aux affaires
étrangères merci beaucoup madame alliot
marie claire si elle avoir été avec nous
nous justement on s'est rendu à mme ans
après le début de la révolution place
maïdan le nouveau parlement a été mis en
place à l'intérieur beaucoup de nouveaux
et surtout beaucoup de défis
reportage de jérôme rabin
non
18 février 2014
la place maïdan s'embrase et à kiev
depuis la vie a repris son cours malgré
la guerre qui se poursuit à l'est du
pays la révolution est encore dans tous
les esprits
on fait les un nom des débuts de maidan
et moi ce n'était en fait ces événements
qui se sont passés ici même permettre à
tous les ukrainiens de venir ici pour se
rappeler de ceux qui sont morts pour la
liberté de l'ukraine et son indépendance
je ne regrette pas cela devait arriver
my d'âge car nous ne pouvions plus vivre
ainsi un an plus tard c'est aussi la
rentrée pour le premier parlement
ukrainien post révolution un véritable
renouveau puisque la moitié des députés
n'a aucune expérience politique
parmi eux ils sont nombreux à voir
militer à maidan mustapha nayem et même
celui qui a appelé sur facebook au
premier rassemblement à l'époque il
n'avait été qu'un millier à répondre
présent je pense que tout ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui dans notre pays n'est
que la continuité de maidan car maidan
n'est pas fini j'espère que les gens qui
sont venus au parlement directement de
maidan seront la force principale de ce
changement
et qui c'est une large coalition pro
européenne qui est désormais au pouvoir
l'ancienne égérie de la révolution
orange de 2004 ioulia timochenko ont
fait partie espère que l'union sacrée
tiendra je veux souhaiter dans ce jour
solennel qui est le premier jour de
travail de ce parlement est aussi le
jour de mon anniversaire je veux
souhaiter l'unité de cette coalition est
qu un véritable progrès se mettent en
place pour l'ukrainien
l'ukraine est aussi un pays en guerre
les combattants parti à l'aise sont
considérés comme des héros est courtisé
par les partis politiques
pour moi c'était plus facile de faire la
guerre parce qu'ici au parlement pour
réaliser les objectifs que le peuple m'a
délégué il pour faire face à de nombreux
obstacles à une résistance beaucoup plus
forte qu'elle ait une union sacrée pour
l'indépendance de l'ukraine qui doit
faire face à d'immenses défis
premier d'entre eux la situation
économique l'inflation flirte avec les
20 % sur un an et la grivnas la monnaie
locale s'effondre au grand dam de la
population
qu'est-ce que vous avez un proposé de
pas très cher vous
la moyenne
je peux vous proposer cette pièce là on
vient celle ci ici ou encore celle là
maïwenn sais je reçois 1800 grives
nasscom retraite
j'ai travaillé pendant 49 ans comme
professeur d'histoire et ma retraite et
2800 grivnas ce choquant mais moi je
recherche les produits les moins chers
on va voir dans tous les marchés de la
ville pour comparer car nous les
retraités on n'a pas le choix
dans ce marché comme dans le reste du
pays
la situation inquiète et notamment la
baisse du pouvoir d'achat
oui bien sûr les prix ont peu augmenté
ils augmenteront encore c'est inévitable
car des gens sont morts et les villages
sont vides il n'y a personne pour
nourrir le bétail
les chants sont en jachère il n'y a
personne pour élever le bétail
combien c'était il ya quelques mois il y
a quelques mois c'était degree menace de
moins par morceau soit 15 % moins cher
environ
en manque de liquidités le pays attend
27 milliards de dollars de la communauté
internationale le conflit avec la russie
et l'accord d'association avec l'ue a
signé le 27 juin dernier bouscule
l'économie ukrainienne bon travail cette
accroche préparez vous déjà parlé des
côtés positifs de l'accord d'association
avec l'union européenne car lieux a
ouvert ses marchés à l'ukraine et durant
cette courte période déjà les
exportations vers l'union européenne ont
augmenté de 15%
un bouleversement rapide qui doit
s'accompagner de nombreuses réformes qui
vont de l'économie à la vie politique en
passant par le système judiciaire un
défi immense pour la toute jeune
assemblée
aujourd'hui on ne peut pas parler d'un
problème principal il faut plutôt dire
que toutes les réformes sont
prioritaires on doit les mettre en place
simultanément
parce que par exemple une réforme de
l'administration publique ne sera jamais
efficace une réforme dans un pays qui
panse encore ses plaies et commémore ses
morts tout reste à reconstruire la
révolution ne sera finie que lorsque
l'ukraine aura surmonté les nombreuses
épreuves qui l'attendent
voilà donc pour ce reportage à maidan de
jérôme rabier on voit les défis auxquels
l'ukraine est confrontée et pour en
parler je reçois arnaud danjean bonjour
bonjour merci d'être avec nous et ron
fair temps référente de pardon lopez
aguilar merci d'être avec nous vous êtes
député européen espagnol ancien ministre
de la justice arnaud danjean je me
tourne vers vous est-ce qu'on peut
rester confiant quant à l'avenir de
l'ukraine quand on voit les défis
auxquels doit faire face
oui parce qu'il faut être confiant c'est
un pays en transition depuis longtemps
d'ailleurs on se focalise beaucoup ici
sur la juste titre sur les événements
qui sont survenus depuis un an et le
côté dramatique avec le conflit à l'est
la révolutionnaire mais c'est un pays
qui est en transition depuis des années
voire des décennies qui éprouvent des
difficultés économiques et structurelles
depuis longtemps mais il faut rester
confiant parce que je crois qu'en
particulier
on a eu des événements porteur
d'optimisme qui sont les élections les
élections présidentielles les élections
législatives d'abord qui se sont bien
déroulées hormis dans les territoires
contrôlés par les séparatistes pro
russes mais qui se sont bien déroulées
sur l'ensemble du territoire et qui ont
donné des majorités claires sans aucune
ambiguïté en faveur de d'élite pro
européennes qui sont aussi des gens
compétents que ce soit le premier
ministre ou le président donc il ya
quand même des facteurs d'optimistes
même si le fond de crise reste là et ça
sera durable alors justement rentrer un
anneau lopez aguilar
on voit que la crise de liquidité existe
toujours c'est ce qui avait conduit en
fait à l'époque
le début de la crise le le cren
s'étaient tournés en fait vers la russie
et avait levé la possibilité d'accords
d'association avec l'europe
il manque 27 milliards d'euros il ya
d'étrange qui doivent être versés à
l'ukraine mais est-ce que ce sera
suffisant selon vous je crois pas
c'était assurément difficile c'est vrai
c'est d'incitation des transitions mais
aussi en situation de conflit c'était
sur des conflits qui a lieu dans la
frontière des mois ci nash de l'union
européenne et à l'intérieur du conseil
de l'europe
il faut dire que c'est pas la première
fois que dans l'histoire du conseil de
l'europe il y à des pays en conflit
entre deux ça c'était les cadets
l'arménie et l'azerbaïdjan c'est le cas
de la géorgie et la russie
et pas par accident encore une fois le
calme contre la russie c'est accomplir
ce moment difficile et ils font
l'engagement de l'union européenne ue
ainsi pas que cela veut dire que ce sera
suffisant mais vignolo paix ne s'est pas
assez engagé
je crois que l'union européenne doit
engager encore du plus d'accord il doit
surtout accroître sahara et les ventes
internationales comme un acteur
globalement relevant dans la diplomatie
et de la coopération est aussi dans la
résolution des conflits dans la région
du voisinage direct de l'union
européenne l'union européen et voisines
des la russie et vos signes de lorraine
alors il faut s'engager avec tous les
deux les acteurs et là-haut son mieux
pour faire la différence
alors justement à ce propos d'engagement
de l'union européenne vis-à-vis de la
russie est donc de vladimir poutine
une des députés que nous avons
rencontrés à ce nouveau parlement avait
une question à vous poser je voudrais
qu'on l'écoutent
je voudrais dire que la guerre en
ukraine la situation en ukraine a besoin
du soutien international
car soutenir la paix en ukraine avec
l'aide de nouveaux investissements en
termes de temps de moyens et d'argent
c'est la garantie de la stabilité pour
l'europe et pour le monde entier car
l'ukraine aujourd'hui est un véritable
test pour le monde en matière de
démocratie
est-ce que vous soutenez les vrais
droits et les vraies valeurs
fondamentales ou alors vous considérez
que les conséquences économiques et le
gaz russe moins chères sont plus
important pour vous
alors denjean ça elle mérite d'être
clair est-ce qu'on joue pas un double
jeu vis-à-vis de la russie vladimir
poutine on a besoin du gaz donc on lui
fait une danse du ventre et derrière il
n'y a pas de y'a pas de double jeu il ya
à faire face luce avec lucidité et
responsabilité à une situation qui est
une situation complexe
oui on choisit le droit le droit
international en reconnaissant la
souveraineté et l'intégrité de l'ukraine
et en la défendant
c'est à dire en amenant à des
négociations qui respecte cela donc on
soutient sans ambiguïté le droit
international
ensuite la façon dont on peut j'allais
dire concrètement mécaniquement aboutir
à ces résultats c'est quelque chose
d'éminemment compliqué c'est la
diplomatie c'est comme ça dans tous les
conflits alors que quand on voit
françois hollande se rendre dès
d'histoire se rendra à moscou il
discutait avec des dix meilleures
poutines est-ce qu'il ya pas une forme
de double jo je crois qu'il faut il faut
évidemment discuter on a depuis le début
ce soit l'otan que ce soit l'union
européenne on a je crois juste titre dit
que l'option militaire n'était pas une
option et donc la seule option de sortie
c'est une option diplomatique dans la
diplomatie vous discutez y compris avec
des gens j'allais dire surtout avec des
gens avec lesquels vous ne partagez ni
les mêmes objectifs ni parfois les mêmes
valeurs
il faut que la russie fasse aussi des
gestes pour montrer qu'il faut on va
sortir de ce conflit ukrainien vous êtes
d'accord entre fernando lopez aguilar
est ce qu'il faut continuer de parler
avec vladimir poutine ou est-ce qu'il
faut encore plus de sanctions
quel message on envoie à ses
parlementaires d'en poursuivre la
d'ignorer les voisines viennent
poursuivre le d'ignorer en machines
géantes comme la russie bien sûr il faut
aussi lancer un message clair qu'il
n'est pas prêt on n'est pas prêt à céder
à faire des concessions illimité alors
il faut tenir
l'union européenne ce principe ses
valeurs sans engagement avec les droits
fondamentaux avec la démocratie est la
lutte contre la corruption est vraiment
important en situation comme au crâne
alors je crois que la position forte
vers la russie est en train de faire la
différence est en train d d d d d d d
être significatif
la russie accuse l'impact des sanctions
économiques de la pollution économie
citation de la russie n'est pas facile
mais ignorer la russie les passageois
ses jambes mais la part de l'union
européen pas seulement les états membres
c'est le cadet françois hollande le
président de la france mais aussi des
autorités européennes directement
européen il faut s'engager dans les si
la haute représentante et situation
parce que on né peut pas oublier qu'il y
ait un conflit là bas il y à la guerre
là-bas il y à la guerre à l'est dé le
crâne un entrelacs aussi en tradition
militaire directe alors il fait il faut
faire la différence avec la diplomatie
européens
il faut faire des sanctions économiques
il faut changer l'attitude mais il faut
aussi comprendre comprendre la
psychologie et des passerelles vous je
me suis levé ce aguilar quand d'un côté
on va le voir parce que on a besoin du
gaz russe parce que on a un problème
énergétique en europe et que de l'autre
on met en place un embargo des sanctions
qui de toute façon finissent aussi par
assécher et bien les propres producteurs
européens
c'est pas la première fois dans
l'histoire de l'humanité qu'il y at elle
des contradictions dans la gérance en
conflit bien sûr il nous faut une fois
l'énergie reviennent mais il faut aussi
par l'ère de la politique et par la
diplomatique mans de la résolution des
conflits
le crâne augmenter les sanctions parle
denjean non je crois que les sanctions
sont déjà fort tu veux elles portent
déjà leurs fruits
on voit bien que sur le plan économique
et financier alors il ya aussi d'autres
facteurs comme la baisse du prix du
pétrole
nous on voit que l'économie russe est
fortement impacté on voit que le cercle
économique autour de vladimir poutine
est impactée donc les producteurs
européens pour l'instant maintenir les
sanctions alors les rétorsion prises par
par l'administration russe qui impacte
notamment effectivement les producteurs
de produits agricoles européens ça c'est
une problématique européenne c'est à
nous de gérer ça avec des mesures de
compensation
ça montre bien la nécessité pour tout le
monde de sortir de cette crise et d'en
sortir par le haut mais là la balle est
largement dans le camp de la russie la
russie à tous les paramètres de ce qu'on
appelle la fameuse des escalades retrait
des troupes et des matériels russes en
ukraine parce qu'il y en a arrêté de
soutenir des rebelles pro russe qui pour
la plupart sont d'ailleurs pas des gens
locaux se sont pas des des russophones
ducret
qu'ils se sentent en danger pour la
plupart ce sont des mercenaires qui
viennent ici pour mener un combat qui
n'est pas celui des ukrainiens de l'est
donc il faut mettre fin à ce conflit
la clé se trouve largement à moscou
l'europe le moment venu allègera ces
sanctions voire l'élèvera complètement
pour le moment on n'en est pas encore là
malheureusement d'accord alors il ya une
autre actualité qui va vous occupez sur
la cession prochaine à strasbourg manque
la semaine prochaine c'est le vote ou
pas de la résolution pour la
reconnaissance de la palestine
juan fernando lopez aguilar est ce que
vous voterez oui à cette résolution
oui oui c'est important pour vous que
l'union reconnaître au final de la
rédaction la résolution mais je suis
tout à la résolution n'est pas encore
rendue publique geme tient je me tiens
bien sûr amis d'israël
oui j'étais ministre de la justice j'ai
fait de fait une politique vers l'état
d'israël et je continue le président
l'intergroupe parlementaire
d'antisémitisme que c'est très important
et substantiel pour le droit d'israël à
l'existence d'ondés frontières de
sécurité et les conditions pacifiques
avec tout ce poids sens mais bien sûr il
faut être conscient que la détérioration
de la situation régionale avec le
statisme de l'état islamique la menace
des risques bola les roquettes provenant
de la de deir ezzor est où ça cette
saison d'une stabilité de monde et une
réponse claire ou pas très claires de la
part de la communauté internationale
tout particulièrement de la part de
l'union européenne séparément se coupent
sens de faire une déclaration de volonté
mais même si c'est un bolide à mme silva
la l'état palestinienne il ya de la
palestine et la reconnaissance de l'état
de la police mais ce sera symbolique
monsieur aguilar non non pas cette fois
symbolique et politique
ces politiques arnaud danjean vous
voterez oui non oui à priori je veux
très content on verra la rédaction
finale de cette résolution pour une
question de forme est une question de
fond la question de forme c'est que ce
n'est pas dans nos compétences et ce
n'est pas dans les compétences de
l'union européenne de reconnaître la
reconnaissance est un processus national
et je souhaiterais à cet égard qu'il y
ait plus de coordination au niveau
européen sur un gros jour la pression
sur les gouvernements la science et au
conseil de prendre sa responsabilité aux
gouvernements nationaux
sur le fond je pense que c'est prématuré
je suis évidemment pour un état
palestinien je suis évidemment pour la
solution dite à deux états même si elle
a beaucoup de plomb dans l aile
pardonnez moi l'expression
en ce moment c'est vrai que le processus
est bloqué c'est vrai qu'il faut faire
des pressions notamment sur le
gouvernement israélien actuel qui ne
jouent pas le jeu
non c'est que la colonisation a
énormément il ya effectivement une
résolution sans doute appuyé de la part
du reste du du parlement européen pour
inciter pour demander au gouvernement
israélien de faire des efforts pour
autant je ne crois pas que ce soit la
reconnaissance très virtuelle d'un état
palestinien très virtuel qui change la
donne je connais l'argument de ceux qui
disent aujourd'hui on est à un tel point
de blocage qu'il faut des gestes
politiques forts que disait le renverser
la table
moi je pense malheureusement que dans le
contexte actuel ceci n'apportera pas les
résultats escomptés en tant que telle
est la perspective de l'état et
palestiniennes tellement virtuel il y à
la population et les territoires
reconnus par le terrain temps réel et la
colonisation et fait que aujourd'hui les
intérêts 1900 il y à un territoire et il
y a des autres ou les en place il faut
la réconnaissance communauté
internationale bien sûr le parlement
européen s'est pas là dernièrement sur
la question de la ratification des la
condition étatique de la palestine mais
c'est un message politique à redresser
justement la diplomatie des états
membres et bien moi je pense pas que
malheureusement le résultat politics à
celui escompté
si la démarche était aussi vertueuse et
qu'elle avait des impacts un impact
politique fort je serais prêt à y
souscrire je pense malheureusement qu'on
reste dans le registre symbolique mais
avec des effets pervers voire
contre-productif qui sont très
importants mais rien en faire et passez
un bon écoutez ça engage de très longs
débats la semaine prochaine en session
merci messieurs d'avoir été avec nous
nous on se retrouve la semaine prochaine
à strasbourg
ciao